hello and welcome to episode 16 of my
terraforming Master strategy guide today
we're going to look at a game I played
on the master where I went for the card
strategy and this game is quite insane
mainly my opening hand is completely
insane but I'm going to show you so I
actually already cropped this replay
down and I realized I cropped it a
little bit too aggressively maybe so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pause
sometimes when there's an interesting
choice I have to make so I got terractor
I'm gonna go for terractor and the
reason I go for terractor in this game
is that I have a couple of Earth takes
in my opening hand I don't really have a
lot of cards that cost 20 plus here when
it comes to the preload these are not
the best but I'm gonna choose the true
Prelude that actually has a science tag
on it and the whole reason is I want to
play AI Central in the first generation
so this is definitely one of the best
opening hands I've ever had I talked
about this open hand a lot in episode
three the card strategy but the whole
reason this opening hand is insane is
that I can play as Central in the first
generation and on top of that I have two
Earth tag Mega credit amplifiers sword
and I think I have cartel and I have a
couple of other attacks so this end is
amazing and just a cherry on top Olympus
countries is like the best card in the
game when you're going for the cast
reality and then I have a mass converter
I don't quite have five science tag yet
but I have four so I just need to pick
up one more science tag so I can play
Mass converter and then my hand is wow
perfect
yeah bio lab to be honest these are not
the most interesting preludes but they
do come with bit of cards like the plan
production I don't really care about at
this point but it's it's just for the
science take AI Central in the first
generation yeah it's so good man
so I hope this video doesn't go too fast
because I did realize what I watched
this I cropped it a little bit too much
so sabotage here I just use it because I
I already calculated that I could play
my hand even after playing it and worth
noting that's one of the free cards I
got
is a sabotage
[Music]
Luna beam from an asteroid oh that's
interesting that's only because
it has an earth tag so so I'm setting
myself up to for better cartel but I
actually kept another energy production
card in my opening hand I just ended up
not needing it because when I have a
energy production on an earth tag that's
obviously a little better for me right
now
and that's pretty much it AI Central
first generation all I wanted
[Music]
second generation LG I don't know no
this looks good to be honest ghg Factory
this is actually really interesting I'm
gonna pause here in a second because uh
so I'm gonna pause here so we have up to
four cards and when I played this I'm
like all right all of the color look
like trash that's not what I want right
now so you won't believe it but this is
one of the most important decisions of
this game so I'm looking at these four
caps that doesn't look that interesting
to me however there is ghg Factory and
insulation so if you add ghg factories
to the two heat production I already
have that's six heat production that I
can make into Mega credit production so
when you calculating the cost of the
card is like 19 gold just to get these
six Mega credit production so remember
really thinking about this and I'm like
ah screw this man I still have some
Earth takes in my hand I want to play I
have the Earth tag amplifiers I have so
much card Pro I should be able to get
some better engine than this but the
thing is I really don't so so looking
back the correct decision here is
actually to keep ght factory insulation
and play this and then in the Next
Generation then I'm probably gonna play
all the Earth second fastest that
probably would have been a play but the
thing is I have so many other things and
I have like Earth tag amplifiers and I'm
now I'm going to draw two cards and then
I'm going to draw another card with
business Network and I have a lot of
stuff going for me so I think it's the
right decision to not go for these like
kind of sub-optimal Mega credit
production cards when I have so much
stuff in my hand
but it's hard to say because the thing
is in this game I have everything I have
all the card draw I want I have got some
nice quality cards but the one thing I
don't have is Mega credit production my
mega credit production is really good
struggle so right here I get five plus
five for the two uh for the Earth tag so
that's that's that's good enough I mean
my start here I can't complain the start
is completely insane it's very perfect
but from here on out out now I I played
my two Earth amplifiers so I got like I
think 10 mega craters out of these two
cards that's fine but from now on I'm
really struggling to get more Mega
credit production and as we talked about
already you both need mega credit
production and card draw this game has
card draw all over the place but I'm
really struggling with mega credit
production and money income in general
that was really interesting
so I think a lot of people are like I
lost a game of terrifying masks my
opponent has more Mega credit production
what can I do no I came upstairs it's
about so much more than just getting
like a credit production this play this
game here is like the perfect example
so even though I don't get out much make
credit production I'm still gonna Crush
my score was gonna be insane especially
considering that it's gonna be a three
player game and and it's only gonna be I
believe 10 or 11 Generations or
something
so so everything is just working out for
me but I'm just saying that if I had
more Mega credit production to go with
this insane starting hand then I could
definitely edit like I don't know 200
even though it's a three player 11
generation game which is good which is
good usually two two player games can
generate more than 200 especially if
they go to like 14 or something but 11
generations for three players then my
score is gonna be absolutely fine here
foreign so I'm keeping a couple of good
late game cards here like this um a
plant per City card I just kept
yeah looking at Milestones uh once again
we are at generation three so it's not
like I'm gonna pick them up right now
but it is a three player game and I
think I feel like I'm ahead of this
point yeah so here I'm definitely
looking at the Milestone so this guy has
the specialist but I'm thinking well
maybe I mean if he wants it he can claim
at the start of the Next Generation
because he's actually gonna start the
next Generation so I'm just gonna focus
on mobile games I'm gonna sell a card
here because that's just what I need in
order to play integration Shadows so
this is one of the cases even though I
have like a the city card that reduces
cars by one it's actually better for me
to get the immigration shuttles down
because even though I could have gotten
that for one cheaper Next Generation the
fact that I played it now means I have
five more gold Next Generation so that's
more than one goal so some really
interesting cards here I'm looking at
inventor skill the medical lab I think
medical lab would be great if I have a
lot of building tags especially
considering that my mega credit
production could be a little bit better
I mean honestly most of the time when
you're going for the card strategy is
something like a mental skill would be
really good but like I said in this game
I have a lot of card draw and I have
very little Mega credit production so I
think maybe medical lab could be an idea
here but I don't know how many attacks I
have maybe I'll check that I'm gonna go
for invent the skill okay makes sense
anti-gravity holy [\h__\h] it's not even
close yeah let's go
so now now the game has changed and now
Mobile area I don't care about this I
think maybe yeah yeah so industrial
sensor I'm keeping because I can get a
little bit of value on this and I think
it's also because of one of the
Milestones if I remember correctly
but now I have research outposts I have
anti-gravity and to be honest
oh he actually let me get that one okay
yeah well if if it doesn't want the
Milestone then I obviously I have to
take it and I got higher mining
Industries but at this point I have so
much stuff I want to play that I can't
really play Iron Man Industries
so industrial sensor this is also
because of a milestone otherwise it
would have played this later like it
would have been more efficient to play
after anti-gravity technology but this
is definitely because of the other
Milestone I think yeah yeah now I'm
getting I'm steel production that's all
right that's because the general is so
the thing is I know I'm gonna start the
next Generation so this is why this is
um you could even debate if it's still
worth it but it's it's all unset and
done is still a good play because now I
can stop this generation here I'm gonna
pause again yeah because I can start
this generation by claiming this
Milestone I just achieved because I I
know that I can do this because I'm
gonna be first player so there's nothing
they can do to stop me so here we got
commercial District large Convoy to be
honest with all the stuff I have in my
hand is it really worth it to go for
commercial District that's also an
argument to be made for large Convoy I
think the thing is is that I just feel
like I don't have enough Mega credit
production so I really to get the dream
game I really need to get my engine up
and running
so it's maybe also a bit greedy to to
keep large convert just because this cat
gave me like seven week three point in
the late game so it's a tough choice
these are definitely the two cards I
should be looking for here I'm gonna go
for a commercial District
it's okay it makes sense
and then I'm gonna go for hackers I'm
not so sure about hackers man but and
here the last two are not important
I'm not even sure I'm going to keep
hagas yeah okay so maybe I've just kept
hackers so just so nobody's gonna use it
on me that might actually have been been
one of this I don't even think I have
the energy production to do it so so
yeah and I'm gonna take generalists then
I'm gonna draw two cards it's only the
generalist it's only the the one thing
where I really wanted to do it at the
first action
and now somebody's taking the bonuses
and the heat whatever
team repair I mean it's still good
yeah it's a research Outpost so this is
because it has a science tag makes all
my cards cheaper definitely what I want
right now
I think I'm going for the steel down
here because this steel can be used for
some other car
that I have in my hand
oh I'm even looking at the last
Milestone it would be funny if I get
healthy I can't remember but let's see
Development Center Marsh University of
course yeah yeah
so now we're in this phase of the game
where because I have this card
uh what are we cloud seating maybe yeah
because I have this car I kind of need
to also have bad cards in my hand just
so I can cycle so look at this all of
this I'm gonna cycle now
search for life is not great but is
there some other cards that's even worse
it could be windmills yeah it takes a
long time before windmills makes any
sense so
and then what I'm looking for now is
like the last Milestone and also the
anti-gravity technology if I haven't
played it I don't believe I have
so let's see here space elevator it's a
pretty clear car oh mining right I'm
actually thinking about mining right but
space elevator makes a lot of sense fish
looks good Lang claim wait
this Lane claim I think it's just so my
opponent doesn't grieve me
and then I got a jovian Tech that's fine
yeah this looks alright
you could have made the argument that I
should have kept one more card just so I
have something to cycle with but it is
what it is
so I'm going to draw some cards I wonder
what the last Milestone is here I think
I could be in contention to to do
something
but then again even if I can claim the
Milestone I also have anti-gravity
technology here
yeah so this is what I mean release
infinite guesses is not a great cut but
it's not a bad cut either so maybe I
should have kept one more pass just so I
had some trash to cycle because this
card is actually kind of okay
especially considering that it's three
cheaper than normal I think actually I'm
gonna pause here because I think this is
why I didn't go for the Milestone
because I think I blended out of my head
that I want to put anti-gravity
technology and then I'll just have
barely enough resources to play space
elevator afterwards it could even be the
case that the reason it didn't pick up a
bad card in the drafting phase is
because I already did the math and I
thought all right will this generation
just want to play everything to gravity
that one place bass elevator I think
this is maybe one of this so right now
of course I'm paying with free titanium
but I'm not paying with the steel
because I need this deal for the action
afterwards
and to be honest like milestones and
everything it's good and all but this
generation is still amazing like if you
play anti-gravity plus space elevator
whatever man you can have the milestones
at this point oh higher Raiders I
believe this is a card I just picked up
randomly with with something
might as well just grieve a seven system
a little bit
it's free for me so so why not
yeah and at this point I'm thinking all
right these guys are actually
terraforming a lot which is annoying I
don't really want them to terraform that
much because I know that I have the
dream game I know that I'm gonna win
definitely the long game so it's a
little bit annoying there so keen on
ending the game but it is what it is
they're quite companies it's a little
bit late generation six but it only
costs four so of course
why not
and then this card is free so this is
like when I say talk about God mode and
stuff look at all these cheap plays I
have available to me here
and it's only going to get better at
this point so uh all of these cars that
cost like zeros or ones or it's just
very efficient to just play all of these
cheap cards it's really The Snowball
Effect
this one
yeah I guess it's free I don't like this
card Winfield so much but it is free so
it makes sense you could make the
argument that I should have uh because
now I need to cut to cycle so I I cycled
some energy production instead but I
could have also cycled windmills and it
would have been fine
but I guess I don't need the energy
production so maybe it's okay
so here I think bushes maybe but I think
I'm gonna go for a Great Escape in
Consortium
uh to grieve my opponent a little bit
maybe just because I don't cost three
I'm gonna go for Comet and then
colonizer training camp is the last
generation where I can play that so that
kind of works out
so I guess I'm just I'm just hoping that
my opponent decent the purple guy is not
actually gonna gonna terraform oxygen
but we're close to bonus I'm calculating
that it's probably not so I'm not
actually going to take the uh
space event cards which is interesting
okay Tycoon yeah
yeah yeah for sure for sure so I'm
definitely a tycoon I need to do that as
soon as possible and then all right
training camp as soon as possible
because now what it takes so if I'd
waited before doing that then I couldn't
have actually played a car
[Music]
another thing all right I just topped
the good terrible while not
so I gotta be honest I'm like all right
I only have 15 Mega credit production
it's it's kind of unlucky only one steal
only two titanium and stuff but when
everything is said and done I have a
million cards and now I have five
discount of all cards so so this is why
this game is still insane despite the
fact that I don't have to make a credit
production so this is also the point I
made before that even though you don't
have mega credit plug and you can still
go God mode you can still have an
amazing game it's not about
it's not about Mega credit production in
this game it's about so many different
things so many synergies and stuff
so I think this guy yeah he left and now
he comes back and he's confused I think
he just re-locked because of a bug or
something but uh yeah now he's now his
name changed back so all right
so definitely a thing I could have maybe
looked for here is the bonus that's
definitely what should be on my mind
right now the bonus on the oxygen scale
which is one temperature do I have any
ways of consisting that with nine Mega
credits I need like two gold uh it's
kind of rough
but I think my my idea is that I can't
really do anything if they if they do it
now okay they'll do it now that sucks
but in the next Generation I would have
started so I still had a chance of
getting it actually
yeah I'm looking at this I'm like oh
screw it they got it it happens
now I'm getting some more cheap Cuts why
not I still haven't played Iron Man
Industries and I think it's kind of
correct because I had so much other
stuff in my hand I wanted to play but
at this point I think iron mining
Industries is definitely a car I should
be looking for
uh to play in the near future
I think that would make a lot of sense
and
oh this is nice but I also noticed that
I have this annoying search for Life
card I don't know man I've never
actually hit this in my life it never
happened
I like the card because it's a cheap
science tag and stuff but the I might I
might not even use the active because
I'm never lucky I never get it
um yeah I picked up security fleets not
bad at this point
we are reaching the uh actually we're
kind of reaching the end game pretty
fast which is annoying for me but I mean
I'm still not that I'm gonna win it
there's no
uh
question at this point yeah so I'm
selling a car so I can play imported
hydrogen
and I believe uh the reason for this is
I can place it here so I get two planes
plus three plans so that's enough to
make a Greenery
and I think uh definitely it's also
because I'm waiting for my opponents to
pass the generation because then I will
feel confident to just grab this bonus
actually I'm pretty sure they have
passed at this point otherwise I would
have grabbed the bonus before
so even though I didn't get the oxygen
um
bonus then I'm still getting this water
bonus which is nice
so all of a sudden we have three Waters
placed which is not in my interest I
want the game to drag out long but you
know this was just such an efficient
play that I kinda had to go for it
and honestly every time you can get a
bonus even though you're going for the
long game it's probably still worth it
and it looks like oh kind of farming
nice and it looks like it's gonna be
unless it was searched for life was it
oh man
it looks like it's gonna be water that's
the last uh parameters or two to close
the game business Network looks amazing
here
yeah now I'm looking at the awards
I think that makes a lot of sense this
is the time of the game where definitely
their first of all it should kind of be
claimed already but it's not for some
reason Capital looks cool
Capital looks really cool oh and this
one this is an interesting one standard
technology or the plant tag Plantation I
think Plantation is better because I
have like insects and stuff but both of
these cars are really good at this point
that violent hamsters have had insects I
think Plantation is better
also because I'm not sure how many
stand-up practice I'm actually gonna end
up making because I have so many cards
so definitely the right choice so this
looks like a capital to me
no I'm not going to click Capital isn't
that a really good
oh [\h__\h]
oh I remember this so yeah I'm annoyed
now because I don't think capital and
then I'm like all right I don't know
what to do so I'm just gonna pass along
my turn and then this guy like my
opponents are like closing the Heat and
I'm left with thin heat resources so I'm
actually really salty that I didn't just
start the generation placing Heat
but I guess my mind was on this Capital
this is a yeah yeah this is a good place
for Capital
um the five Mega credit production is a
little bit late but I don't know I think
it's still worth it for the three points
that gives me plus
it is the late game I kind of need just
a little bit of of presence on the map a
little bit of City synergy
and now we get to all the green texts so
in the previous generations I didn't I
wanted to play all of these cars but I
had some other stuff that was also
important
but now it's definitely all about
getting all the green text out and
playing insects insects is definitely
what I'm looking for this generation
Optical Zone yeah it's fine
also play into the award by placing it
here and this is what I mean just by
playing this card
and before that I played um what's it
called well enhancers so this alone is a
good play
and then we got all this stuff and look
how cheap it is and then I'm gonna get
Mars and I'm gonna get insects and
all of a sudden these cities I played
here especially the capital all of a
sudden this is like uh it's gonna be
come a lot better because I'm gonna
really catch up in plant production now
for the last couple of generations maybe
it only goes to ten it doesn't look like
it's gonna go this long this game wow
foreign
[Music]
so now I'm at 20 Mega credit production
it's a bit better
but it's still not considering how much
stuff I had is still not great oh man
so satellites I think is still worth it
I have five space tanks I can get a few
more immigrant City I mean I'm obviously
taking the job in Amplified but the
other one could have been immigrant City
just so I could get a cheap City in the
last generation or something but nah I
can play I can play this for three and
all of a sudden I go from 20 to 26. so
it's not like a big deal to be honest
we're still late in the game but it is
something so at this point um I'm
finally where I want to be with the mega
credit production I mean the more the
better but
this is interesting soil Factory Earth
office normally I would think about
Earth's office but I don't think I have
any Earth tanks so
IL Factory does for the one point I
think would make a little more sense
here yeah
oh mineral deposit yeah sure you you
never say no to just getting free steel
especially when you could use it it's
it's really good
make sense grass Heather I think maybe
Heather yeah because it just cost one so
it's really cheap
the annoying thing about this game
normally when I go God mode is like I
have a ton of Mega credits I have a ton
of cars I could just do whatever the
hell I want in this game it's a little
bit different because I kinda have to
restrict myself to making optimal plays
based on the fact that I don't have so
much Mega credit production
so that's stuff like keeping here that
would make sense yeah
and now I don't want to repeat my
mistakes so now I'm just playing two
greeneries as soon as possible so I can
actually get the last available tiara on
the oxygen scale so I don't want to
repeat my previous mistake of not
getting the last three available to you
on the heat so
yeah I mean we'll deposit for zero why
the hell not makes a lot of sense
and then we're gonna knock the city yeah
I think on this map I can place it via
normal City Rules so this makes a lot of
sense also so now my Empire is pretty
much set I don't think I want to build
more cities I don't think I have to play
in production to actually support more
than I have now I think this is fine so
now I really just want to play the rest
of my cards figure out how many
generations are left the good thing
about being in my position here is that
I definitely know that the opponents is
like gonna pass the generation before I
do because I have so many actions I have
so many cars I have so much stuff I can
do so I'm always gonna do if this is the
generation we're gonna close the gamer
or not this is like 1.43 probably fine
so the entire game is in my control is
what I'm trying to say I don't have a
problem with them closing the game now I
don't have a problem with them closing
the game next Generation I would prefer
it if they waited until the next
Generation because I still have 17 cards
in my hand this guy has two cards for
example and I he has Predators that's
annoying
yeah he's definitely stealing from me
what is he stealing some animal with
half a point I think
and yeah just squeeze the last couple of
tea out of a card like this it's gonna
give me like two tier I'm assuming
because the game is probably gonna be
over the next Generation this is also
interesting it doesn't actually give me
heat but it does give me some like floor
plan production so I must have done the
math and figured out that this is
probably worth it why the hell did I do
this though
that's interesting
normally I would play this in the last
generation
oh man that sucks but I think I I played
these greenhouses before because of
insects yeah so it's still debatable
it's like do I think that there's gonna
be one more City in the Next Generation
if there are two more cities or
something then this would not have been
a good play but I must have just
imagined that there would be only one
more City in the last generation because
normally I don't think greenhouses is a
good indicator to play in six it's it's
a normally insect is better to just play
in the last generation usually that
gives a meal plan this way
but at this point these only minor
things it doesn't matter that much
selling something why am I selling it I
could sell this I must have an idea
of playing some sort of
oh it's a tow Station Philadelphia toll
station
I mean it cost five how much it give me
seven so I'm like squeezing another two
make a credit out of playing this car
actually only one because otherwise I
could have sold the car so I don't know
is it worth selling cars for this maybe
I guess I I didn't really have much to
do with these cards anyway
so yeah so two points on this card it's
fine I'm assuming I have some sort of
animal worth two
I don't even know if I have actually
what about the awards here
oh my God I still haven't played eye
mining Industries I said
I have three amplifiers in my hand I
think this uh
oh lichen this one is interesting this
one is really interesting because if I
remember correctly I'm gonna be having
some issues yeah I'm not sure if I keep
lichen here yeah
[Music]
because it's one of those cards that's
like kind of good for me but at the same
time I have three amplifiers in one
place so if this is actually the last
generation I could have just screwed
myself by keeping Legend So I think this
is why I didn't do it but it's it's once
again these are minor things
[Music]
um
so
definitely oh my God decomposes I would
have loved to get this a bit early in
this game
but still getting it now for free
it's fine
um
it's so hard it's just gonna be the last
generation of stakes resourceful
no
it's actually I think I still want to go
to 11 generation 11 if I can I think my
opponents if they had been I think they
probably knew they were going to lose so
it doesn't really matter but what they
should have done that being said is they
should have closed the game now or maybe
even in the previous generation because
in the last couple of generations I'm
gonna I'm gonna get so much
but the interesting I can't remember if
this goes to 10 or 11.
if it goes to 11 then obviously I don't
want to play my amplifiers now but if it
only goes to 10 then I still need to
have a lot of Mega credit and stuff left
over so I can play my Jovian improvise
so I think I have so many actions what I
should have done technically is just
sick one action pass turn take one
action pass the turn but I think I have
so many actions and I'm like ah they're
still gonna pass before I do so I know
if it's gonna be one more generation
so I'm not I'm not wasting time I'm not
slow playing here that's no point
[Music]
so I did start some awards here
so are we getting one more generation it
would be kind of cool if we did
I think we are at this point they still
need to make two water I don't I don't
think they're gonna do that
search for Life maybe you know not gonna
get it [\h__\h] this cat
[Music]
another passed I think
so now I know there's gonna be one more
generation so my mining Industries I
still play this just for the because it
gives a little bit of engine and because
I might as well uh I have three
amplifiers in my hand so
yeah so now that they passed now I'm
fine making one more water for zero you
might have been wondering why they might
do this earlier because I've added that
earlier then they might have actually uh
uh just closed the game so I really have
to be careful when I terraform
especially when I want the game to drag
out
and the city and I believe this was a
stand-up City just so I can get some
nice placements for my green racer
makes sense
I'm I can't really recognize these
Awards here but I think one of the
awards is probably next to water estate
dealer could that be the case it's
definitely the the cards that cost 20
plus that makes sense I'm definitely
winning that one
but I wonder what the other one is I'm
sure I'm not sure
invinces Guild
once again it's a science tag I have
some science energy
it's okay but it's not it's not really
an amazing card at this point because
it's only gonna give me like I can use
it now and then I can use the Next
Generation this is trash and then and
also with loading the cards have been
reshuffled so probably all the good good
cards are gone anyway so
but I have some stuff I can do I think
regular ethers yeah it's not good enough
but I have a little bit of of this media
archives is definitely gonna be clutch
I'm gonna wait until the next Generation
because I have so many events in my hand
and maybe my opponent is also going to
play some events
so it doesn't really make sense to play
it now I don't think
[Music]
yeah we're gonna wait we're gonna chill
all good
[Music]
uh although this sucks man commercial
District I guess just for the VP yeah
I think that makes sense the rest of
them are pretty useless
and this card is like a Greenery for my
opponent yeah there we go legend I I
knew there was something about this car
so I just said no to it in the previous
generation because I thought they would
be the last
and now I'm like all right now okay
apparently the last generation wasn't
the last I could have played in the last
generation
so it's a celebrity and this is it like
okay I see
so it's kind of ironic that I get Legend
two generations in a row and I should
have just picked it up in the previous
generation but you know I didn't know if
I was gonna I didn't know we were gonna
go to 11 instead of ten generation so
I I can I can defend myself on this one
so the last award I should really look
at this one so State dealer might look
interesting what am I what am I doing
huh I'm getting one more City
what about the last award don't it no
maybe I'm not sure I can win it
industrialist estate dealer yeah okay I
see I can probably win a state dealer
but is it really worth okay I'm going
for it
so it's a little bit risky to go for a
state dealer like this
and here is a really interesting choice
I believe yeah so this Greenery looks
ugly but this is because of the estate
dealer because of the estate dealer and
the thing is you might be thinking oh I
just kept commercial District why didn't
I put commercial District in in between
those my my opponent's two cities and
stuff
and it might have been better but uh the
thing is I still have this problem of
not having enough Mega credit so I think
I might not even play commercial
District so this is why I just wanted to
ensure that I get the um
the estate dealer right here right now I
think this is my reasoning for doing for
doing it like this
and at this point I still have
amplifiers in my hand so the cast has to
be really good if I'm going to consider
new cars at this point I don't have as
much money as I wanted
but I don't think there's any race right
now I I think I'm fine
I spend my plans
[Music]
and I secured the Steep dealer as much
as I can I think the desert settler is
already mine
I think I'm Gucci
Birds is really interesting I think I
have a is maybe it's the case that I
don't have an animal worth one animal
per
one with one Victory Point per animal
yet so it could be that I have to play
Birds just so I can get more value out
of my last few cards that gives me
animals could be could be like this
[Music]
and also like we talked about playing
birds in the last generation is just a
way to grieve my opponents in this game
it I think I'd already checked them so
it doesn't really do much oh yeah and
here's another reason I have violent
enhancements when I have vile enhancers
then Birds is definitely worth it at
this point because now it's going to
give me two points just for playing in
the last iteration it only cost me five
gold plus three for the car so yeah this
one for example
so this one can go on Birds now
otherwise it wouldn't have had a an
animal with
it would have been a little bit worse
because then I had to put it on some of
the other animal cars that only gave me
like half a point per animal so so Birds
is actually pretty clutch it's going to
end up giving me four points I guess
nothing from Titan if I play this card
then I definitely calculated I can also
play the last German amplifier
terraforming Ganymede
and it makes sense
there's actually I mean look at all
these high quality cards in my hand
there's so much stuff I want to play it
all but I just have to do the math at
this point and look at the solution oh
man uh yeah I don't think I don't think
Legend would what's the play ironically
and also commercial District was not the
play either I was also too greedy so now
I'm actually selling some cards once
again just so I can play this important
nitrogen is is probably the best
available option right now
so I could get two more on birds and
stuff like this so Birds end up giving
me six point it's pretty good
can I get a anything else out of my hand
it doesn't look like it I can get Legend
oh man just for the ecological Zone it
actually ended up giving me one point
which is funny
because I got one more uh animal take on
on what's it called ecological so
so there are a couple of good cards on
my hand still but all said and done I'm
happy with this game man it's uh I just
know when I see the starting hand I had
on this game it's no question this game
is going to be amazing
so
and I think I had most of the stuff I
wanted I had a lot of good Synergy I had
like
the brand production could have been
better could have been a bit sooner holy
hell I only have 40 seconds I just
realized this yeah
yeah when you're going god mode on the
app even though you have like no
animations going on you know you take
the fastest animation possible you still
have to wait for animation there's still
a thing a little bit so 45 minute game I
think I think this was a 45 minute game
it just goes really quickly
so get all the Milestones I get all the
awards
can't complain
and then all the cities all the cards in
the end is where I'm really making my
points so 168 pounds is a really good
score especially considering this is
three players and and and we only went
to 11 Generations
ironically it's still like 100 less than
my best on the Mars app but we are gonna
cover that in part two so that's gonna
be the next video but that was a
two-player game in 14 Generations that's
how I made like a hundred more points
than this so this game I think was
really cool I think I just have to show
you this one because I got so much stuff
out of my card draw and all my synergies
so even though I didn't have a lot of
gold I didn't have a lot of money income
it was still like a really crushing game
and I it's it just speaks to it it's not
only about Mega credit terraforming
masks it's really cool
so thank you so much for watching and
see you for the next one which is gonna
be uh my high score on the marsup to 78
points or something it's gonna be great
we'll see